Renee the girly pop oh you had such a
roller coaster of an experience in that
house uh so get comfortable because we
got a lot to chat about
um you and that booty of yours you ready
to go yes I am
nice to meet you okay so listen tell me
how are you feeling being out of the
house and now being in jury
I stated walking out those doors I did
have quite the ride in that house and I
felt like I fought through every single
moment that I could and I thought that
was the first time in the house that I
really saw myself taking it to the end
of it being a tangible thing
um so to have that just slip through my
fingers at the last second there was
super devastating but I'm so glad to uh
be at Jury as well to get this part of
the experience I'm a fan I'm Die Hard
fan at that so this is just another side
I get to see yeah absolutely all right
so listen throughout the entire season
you know you thought like when when on
the Block and you know this time was no
different you after that awkward veto
ceremony uh I gotta know like what was
going through your mind after you know
it was between you and Daniel
oh with the V oh yeah The veto ceremony
right when I was put up next to Daniel I
knew I was going to have a little bit of
trouble Daniel is like the definition
and epitome of a lovable social player
throughout the game I wasn't really that
top like lovable like player that you
would never think to put on the Block I
really had to do work in the middle of
the house and behind the scenes so to go
up against someone who really hasn't
touched the block until that point and
has these great relationships
um he was like another Johnny in that
sense of no one really wants to get rid
of Daniel because you just love him so
much so I knew I was going to have an
uphill battle with that okay all right
well listen we gotta talk about the fact
that you know you tried to smooth things
over with Ty you spoke to him after your
HOH week and you had and I say and I
quote you said you wanted to beat the
best in the end game was that your
actual game plan like had you made it
past this week a thousand percent I got
that advice from the queen herself
Koozie she told me you know when you get
out the end I want to see someone beat
the best and to be the best we need to
be the best so I really internalized
that and I wanted to take that with me
and I think the game that I was playing
throughout the season
um contrast and ties in a nice way we
both had to fight really hard in this
game but in different ways he's a
competition beast but then I had to pull
through on the social end so I think
that would have been a really fantastic
dynamic in contrast to seeing the finale
so I definitely would have taken him to
the end for that reason
okay all right well listen you found
yourself pitching to Claudia who is your
own Ally you know asking for her like
pers to persuade Ty to keep you
um why do you think that didn't work in
the end
Claudia's gameplay throughout the season
was really interesting in the sense of
like when Claudia is good she's good and
as much as I wanted to you know wanted
her to fight for me I knew you know she
wasn't gonna have that that need and
desire unless she was on the Block to
fight for it so when I was trying to get
her on my side and to see I know that
she deep down is on my side but I think
with her stance in the house and time
being the stronger competitor she had to
jump ship when she needed to jump ship
to save her game and so she wasn't as
you know forthcoming with her her
Persuasions with Ty I think I don't
think it went super super priming I'm
I'm here so
um yeah I was interesting to see but I
think it's been a pattern in her game so
far okay all right well listen we
finally got to find out what those
Wendy's points were okay like we were
waiting
um so what was your strategy going in to
you know the Wendy's situation once you
saw all your points
well first off I hope falsely misled me
into thinking I was gonna get his point
so they were a little lower than I
thought however I knew if I kept a
straight face that maybe some people
might think I I would have koozie's
point so I didn't really want to share
points at the beginning which it allowed
me to get collect something in that
sense because Claudia could have outbid
me no problem with her points
um so I went in at first not telling
anybody but then once we started telling
everybody then it was pretty easy to get
out bid
all right well how do you feel about the
prizes that everyone won
oh my gosh some of them were just
absolutely heart-wrenching with the
phone calls and the videos I was I'm
sure you saw bawling my eyes out once
that phone popped up it's something like
so meaningful in that house and you
really don't know the impact it'll have
on you until you see it
um but with everything else like the
strategy session with to Sean that was
something I was really highly wanting to
bid on um I was a little low on the
points there so I think that would have
been a great thing or The Plea to the
jury those are really really strong
things for your game that you could
really ask that if you leverage them
properly right okay well was there
anything that you wish you'd been more
on
definitely my phone call with my family
I have like something in my gut tells me
maybe my Nana was on the other end and
that's my rock I call her every day so
it's not be in contact with her for this
long I definitely wish I've been a bit
more but I a part of you was torn
because it was Anika's birthday and I
wanted her to get you know talk to her
fam so that's something I wish I'd been
more on and maybe even just at least bid
on the tishon one but yeah okay well
listen throughout the season you worked
with groups of people
um but you had a really strong bond with
the girly pops now I would love to know
like what your relationship with shanea
and Claudia meant to you not only in the
game but in real life
oh my gosh where do I begin with those
girls those were like my ride or dies of
the season from the get-go and Yumi and
SHINee were gonna be like this because
you know when when you get stuck in a
net together for a little while it
really creates a different type of bond
and you know we roomed together we were
bed mates and all that so
um she was really like a person I leaned
on a lot
um in terms of just like emotional
support Nene does not have a backbone
is truthfully the sweetest human ever I
could be a little petty sometimes so we
balance each other out really nicely but
she was someone especially when she used
that veto on me
um that spoke to me larger than the game
like we had a moment after that ceremony
and I was like you are the first you're
basically a stranger to me and you were
willing to stick your neck out when no
one else everyone else was telling you
not to do it and even talking about it
now it gets me emotional because it's
like I've never had that like selfless
just giving of something when no one was
on my side at that point so
um my bond with Nene goes deeper than
anything I know and Claudia is the same
way and we developed our bond a little
bit later in the game
um and she is someone that you know she
will she's gonna get feisty there with
you she'll be right by your side you
know we both have a little you know
Petty fun in us so she was someone
really that could feed off that energy
with me and she's hilarious so
um I love them to death truthfully I
think we're gonna have great friendships
outside of here I love it okay well
listen you I got to talk about this
because being a strong woman and working
with strong women was obviously very
important to you and you even mentioned
it in your final plea I want to know
what would your message be to Future
women who are hoping to play this game
when you step foot in this game you're
gonna see because the challenges the
thing with challenges it's really
interesting because it's such a big
stage and a lot of the times with these
physical ones the guys really do look
like they dominate it from the beginning
so you know I've seen players in the
past feel like that they need to like be
in an alliance with these guys in order
to move forward I just want anything
else walking into the game to know find
your people if you find girls that you
connect with do not turn against them
work with them be strong together find
your assets leverage it together you can
be a competition Beast you can be a
social strategist and you could be a
strong woman doing it and I have been
dying to see a collective like a female
Alliance stick through the entire game I
know I know here I know you don't do and
I was and so to see something a little
bit like as Free People continue to move
on and not separate after a while was
something super super meaningful and I
would encourage any females walking into
the game to work together stick together
you know don't let these boys run you
over don't let them tell you what to do
you you win your stuff and you do your
damn thing hmm okay all right you heard
it from her booty okay she's telling you
all the things okay well listen you went
from dead last week one
um to being HOH week eight and you were
nominated five times over the season
what was the standout highlight moment
um for you while playing this game
the HOH was a huge one I think it's
really easy to get in your head about
the game and I knew what I could offer
inside the house I think the biggest
stage of the game is actually inside the
house but because we lived there we
don't really notice it as much
um so I was just even though my hands
were tied I was on the Block multiple
times I just needed a couple people to
see the value I could bring strategy
wise and what I could leverage for a
group and how how I could help a group
move forward in the position that I was
in
um so to do that I think I'm skirting
around the question here but um what was
what was the main question what was that
highlight moment for you in this game oh
yeah so being dead last and everything
and having that label on me I was kind
of like burdened by that for a while so
after the Fatal fees I knew I needed
something I knew I needed actually like
a tangible win in order to start showing
people the type of player that I was
um so for that HOA to come in and it'd
be a mental comp I went in there and I
was like you were not getting a single
thing wrong you you step on those steps
and you get those questions right so I
think that shifted people's perspectives
of being game wise as a player awesome
okay well
um I gotta know how does it feel to have
survived again and again making it to
final fives like what does that say
about you as a player
listen those first few weeks I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna lie to you during
David Santino's Visa I really didn't
think I was gonna make it that far I was
like I'm gonna be tied to this block
until something messes up and then they
end up sending me home whether I'm upon
a Target who cares whenever you hit that
block there's a very high chance you can
go home so the fact that I made it to
final five my whole thing was to use my
HOH to set myself up for that
anticipated double that I was expecting
to come
um and so once we moved through that and
I was in the final five I really did see
I had my funnel through with Cece and Ty
um I saw it to the end so to make it to
that checkpoint from where I started and
how I felt from the beginning was
absolutely such a reassuring thing to me
I really truly didn't see it at the
light at the end of the tunnel at one
point so to make it there and especially
with the journey I had and things speaks
volumes to my resiliency and my ability
to persevere in that game
okay well listen Renee you might be out
of the house but you aren't out of the
game now I gotta know what will you be
looking for in a player that makes them
worthy of your vote
I think a big thing with the people that
I want to see in finale is I want them
to capture the energy of our season we
definitely had a very very unique cast
to come in and we had a lot of unique
twists and things that happened and
there was a lot of adversity in this
season so I want to see how someone was
able to get through their own
adversities how they had their hand and
moves how they strategize how they
pulled out compliments when they needed
to
um but I think anybody has a fair chance
if they're able to pitch it properly at
the end
um but I really really want to see how
someone went through the grit not just
kind of start really nicely because of
their position in the house and kind of
just let people do the moves that they
needed to I want to see how you were
involved in that process
okay well lastly as of right now and you
know I gotta ask who do you think is
taking the win for BB can 11. oh
I really think there's a really high
chance it's going to be a toss-up
between times CC right now I think just
competition wise they're very very
strong and I see them pulling themselves
even on their own through to the end
because they are just so competitively
strong however I think you know Daniel
has a very good chance of of getting to
that end there because of his
positioning in the house so
um definitely I'll put my bets on maybe
time CC right now but I could see a
tying Daniel
um at the end there too
okay all right well thank you again
Renee you know you made it to jury you
made it to the jury uh you have so much
of this experience to still enjoy and I
can't wait we all can't wait to see how
it turns out so congratulations and
welcome to this beautiful big brother
family thank you so much
thank you it's nice to meet you bye